welcome to this video playing a
grandmaster my car 1985 from Belarus
right yeah there are named in there
Nikita mayor of 25 70 something okay
yeah i probably have played in before
right to order three asthma squat on the
shaky bishop check who could have easily
gone to see five okay the bogo with a
sideline 56 that i think is pretty am
pretty decent for black can can play
that especially you can play that ass
black without any great theoretical
workload just leading to a flexible
enter and solid position yeah blacks
position is very compact and you can
later choose what to do in the center go
with a 5 with c5 and another entirely
different ideas to play G 594 gaining
space on there on the Kings side I'm
waiting a bit intro interesting book g1
yeah okay the castle g4 is the idea that
much is clear yeah I wonder if I should
um should play G 594 anyway
of course I can also play I'm solid
moves it's a bit tricky with the King
here okay let's do this yeah taking on G
30 and detune now the g3 Bishop is often
a long-term problem with c4 c5 coming so
I rather take that
yeah I wonder about long castling here
you still has the space advantage
the other way to put the king was King
f8 to be seven but I don't really like
that idea check check
okay you're really taking it in playing
rook c8 so how to set up in the center
may be here the exchanging Queen sir
should be always okay for me I have
Queen f5 check activating the Queen
Abbott d5 maybe he cannot really place
in five
what does double here let's just double
on the C file why not an IT form then I
have forgot about 94 that's not good no
good way to protect us and rook see 496
mmm
that's not ideal to say the least what
the what a funny for Kim oh my yeah this
wasn't the necessary this was totally
unnecessary loss I mean totally I just
played d5 instead of allowing idea for
black it's just completely okay
well now this unfortunately very little
counter play but time morning well I'll
still continue a bit let's see how he
how he wins it actually probably it may
be at the right janitor return and
exchange
hmm I get the night night to learn to
you for there would still be some hope
but it's not easy to do check yeah yeah
it's obviously right you can just take
this okay where's the button here it is
yeah lack resigns yeah I really don't
like to lose like that I mean white is
absolutely nothing here if at all I mean
check do I just need to play 25 here and
like it's perfectly okay this night is
not a good piece and there is a very
little that white can do here just a
normal position when the black is not
better or anything but I have no problem
whatsoever after that 94 I am just in
trouble just silly you know here your
black has no decent move anymore I
cannot cover the pawn Brooks is 65 is
just not working yeah and here we got
exactly yeah Queen g6 is not running
into the fork but it's also not very
attractive yeah this is basically the
same was more or less can one new firm
blunder here check allowing this 94 move
with this I'm perfectly okay yeah after
94 luster quite quite quickly okay
thanks for watching